cast IRL will be live in Miami with
Patrick Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt
Gates and Luke gradkowski join us there
get your tickets by clicking the link in
the description below or by going to
timcast.com we got this from The New
York Times and I love the way they
headlined this McCarthy facing an ouster
and a shutdown orders an impeachment
inquiry I just want to pause real quick
because the news is McCarthy actually
made a very succinct and precise
statement about why there should be an
inquiry into the uh potential High
crimes and misdemeanors abusive power of
President Joe Biden I was actually
fairly impressed and uh for no reason
the New York Times includes this this
additional information notice the commas
how about a headline that says McCarthy
orders an impeachment inquiry and
nothing else yeah that's the appropriate
news headline but of course they want to
add nonsensical context to alter your
perception on what is actually happening
they're trying to make it seem like
there's no evidence they're trying to
make it seem like he's only doing this
because he's facing serious pressure but
the reality is we have the evidence most
of you have already seen it we'll go
over a lot of it and talk about it but
here's the news in the New York Times
They say
McCarthy's decision to unilaterally
announce an impeachment investigation
with no formal house vote entwined the
Republican investigations into Mr Biden
with the funding fight that is rattling
the capital it appeared to be a bid to
quell a brewing Rebellion among
ultra-conservative critics who have
accused the speaker of not taking a hard
enough line on spending blah blah blah I
just gotta say
look we're at the point where people
have access to information outside of
these corporate sources and I do think
when you look at even CNN's polling on
this they found 55 percent of people
believe that Joe Biden was behaving
inappropriately as a pertained to
barisma and the you know withholding
money people are waking up to what's
going on so Joe Biden should be
impeached he should have been impeached
and he never should have been elected in
my opinion but if he gets elected
because people voted to elect him fine
but I actually think Joe Biden should
have been convicted of criminal offenses
before he even got into office granted
maybe we didn't know enough fine but
when Trump started to look into these
crimes what happens they impeach him
curious what you guys think yeah no it a
hundred percent and the the line now it
was trending all day on Twitter the
phrase without evidence so they've all
gotten their marching orders now that
this is how they're going to cast this
process that it's illegitimate you know
they've gone after Donald Trump they've
gone after all of us for being
illegitimate illegitimate voters
illegitimate president actually Joe
Biden button is the actual illegitimate
president but this is how they go and
the marching orders have gone out that
there is no evidence there are mountains
of evidence uh this man not just from
when he was vice president but from he
when he was a sitting U.S senator all
the way through the vice presidency and
you know what guys nobody is talking
about what he might be doing now I mean
he is the sitting president of the
United States and nobody is talking
about what he could be doing now you
know also tease out the other point
about this people have been so focused
on the fact that he has gotten a ton of
money tens of millions of dollars
enriching himself and his family by
using Hunter Biden as The Bag Man but
nobody takes it to the next logical
point which is the reason that we are
going to have this impeachment which is
that Joe Biden took these tens of
millions of dollars to change American
policy that so that is the two direct
things that the founders actually put in
the Constitution defined for impeachment
bribery and treason and other crimes and
misdemeanors but if we can prove and I
think we certainly can because we have
tons of evidence here that he engaged in
both actions this man needs to be
removed from office like yesterday I
have a question for you for you then
what do you think happens
should there be an impeachment right the
house finds him finds that there is an
impeachment that needs to happen goes to
the Senate and the Senate finds him not
guilty because it is going to find him
not guilty because we don't control that
body so so they're gonna you know quit
him on that and he will continue
Assuming he's able to physically but
that's not really the point right the
point like the Democrats did with Trump
Democrats with Trump had no evidence
Trump did nothing wrong they ran through
two fake impeachments without a vote
these are the new rules now right yeah
so now we're going to follow those rules
and all of a sudden the Democrats have a
huge problem with it but the point is to
air out all of this evidence regardless
of how it ends in the Senate you go and
do the right thing the house has all of
this evidence impeach the man have it as
part of the historical record get all of
the evidence on the record and then
allow the American people to see it just
one thing I don't I know I don't want to
come off like I was saying that I or I
don't want to give you the impression
that I was that I'm against the idea
because that's not the case at all but
my concern is I feel like you're correct
about the evidence is it's overwhelming
it is clear that Hunter Biden was a Bag
Man it is clear that he was giving him
money to his father because of the
things that his father could do I don't
see a whole lot of
a whole lot of room wiggle room in in
the in when you present the evidence
just the stuff that I've seen personally
um
that being said
like what does that say for the U.S like
the Donald Trump stuff everyone knew
that it was kind of a hack right it was
just a garbage job because they didn't
like him and it wasn't actually that he
did significant things the idea of
Hunter Biden having receipts of actual
uh wire transfers actually sending money
to his his dad and all the stuff of the
emails saying he's doing it 100 so when
it comes out and then they it like when
that comes out and then we have a
situation where he does not get found
guilty because that's what I strongly
believe wouldn't happen what does that
say for the countries and I'm looking
for more of an opinion than an actual
you know let it be said it says a lot
it's uh look with the the indictments of
Donald Trump with everything we're
seeing in the January 6th case and
everything we don't see with the Riots
of the White House on May 29th or the
riots in DC on January 20th 2017. I
think everyone understands and there was
a uh I can't remember the order in which
the pundits said this but for first it
was that there is a two-tier justice
system that there's you know for the
left and the right and then someone
doesn't maybe injected Civics that's
actually three tier it's if you're a
regular person they don't care about you
they might just throw you away throw you
you know throw you in the jail ignore
you it's you're nothing if you're a
privileged Elite establishment you get
protection and ignored and if you're a
trump supporter now they're gonna throw
the book at you every chance they get
well there was one person that called
out the phony Trump impeachment right to
their face and I think the government is
still pursuing legal action against that
individual he may or may not be on this
show right now in a purple shirt but you
know Monica you might want to watch your
step uh saying Joe Biden is
illegitimately elected might be a
criminal offense now so we've got to be
we've got to be very careful well look
we all know as you said Tim that these
establishment corporate Rags always want
to deflect with the headline and they're
well aware that most people don't read
past the headline and so if they can try
to manipulate your Viewpoint via uh
distractive headline or a deceiving
headline then we know they're going to
do that but I think in this case whether
intentionally or not the New York Times
is actually right I think Kevin McCarthy
knows that Republican voters are sick of
him I think Kevin McCarthy knows that
the House Republicans specifically out
of the freedom caucus are sick of him
you know this is a guy that fought tooth
and nail to be the speaker I mean he sat
up there and took the slings and arrows
because he wanted to be the speaker he
made a bunch of promises to House
Republicans and Republican voters and he
hasn't delivered on any of them and so
right now Matt Gates is putting the heat
on speaker McCarthy and I actually think
that I actually think the New York Times
is right I think Kevin McCarthy knows
that if he doesn't do something even if
it's just lip service then Republican
voters and Republicans in the house are
going to realize this guy's an empty
suit I'm afraid of the lip service not
not because not because like there's
some kind of negative repercussions from
the services I'm just so tired of
ineffective and like you know
incompetent Republicans not doing things
not using being in positions of power
and not using power the Democrats have
no issue no hesitation exercising power
when they get into I would say abusing
power fair enough fair enough
um and Republicans are terrified of it
they're afraid of being called names
because they're more comfortable in the
minority right I mean they like being
sort of on defense and they can
fundraise off of it they're more
comfortable in those positions but why
is Matt Gates the only member of
Congress who took to the floor today as
far as I saw and delivered a barn burner
of a speech against Kevin McCarthy look
we are in a war for the future of the
country we can have these weak need
Republicans just being the loyal
opposition anymore and the base gets it
I think a growing number of the American
people understand that the hour is very
late in the country we're at a Tipping
Point here we've been under assault by
these globalists but certainly by the
the global Marxist Revolution for almost
a century starting in the 1930s and
they've been chipping away at our
constitution that's what I'm talking
about
a long time okay and we are now at the
Tipping Point and there's no more we
wait to quote the Predator movie we
ain't got time to bleed that's right
okay and so if you're in a position of
authority in the GOP or or any place in
this movement and you don't get it or
you're in on it with the other side you
gotta go we gotta bounce you and that
includes the speaker of the house if
necessary no more no more political no
more political clubs right and that
seems that seems to be the case in D.C
everybody wants to be in the club and
they want to get along and they don't
want whether it's a Democrat or
Republican kind of looking at them with
the stink eye when they show up at the
parties or when they show up in the
Hamptons and even more to Matt Gage
credit you know last week he actually
gave himself a bit of a tongue lashing
when he came out and he said he you know
what I haven't done enough you're right
I haven't done enough I need to do more
and he comes out and he gives that
speech today and I think that's I really
do believe that's why Kevin McCarthy he
knows that he can't win in the Senate he
knows he can't win in the Senate why
would McCarthy be doing this now what
new evidence is there against Joe and
Hunter Biden that we haven't had for
years we've had the evidence for years
what is he sitting on they're waiting
for the election I I think that's the
only thing that makes sense if they
launch all of this stuff right away 20
you know as soon as they they take they
take the house then they they fire off
their shot and that's it I think if you
look at why they're not I mean look for
you it's been two and a half years and
now all of a sudden they're bringing
this case up it's hitting the news the
the Democrats know the game they're
playing as well wait until 2024 to start
making big arrests raiding houses
arresting people targeting Trump
I think McCarthy is probably alike for
one obviously too many of the Democrats
just roll over and let things their
Democrats go on the speed Republicans Or
democrats go on the speed limit but I
think a lot of this might be if we do
act too quickly then we fizzle out too
quickly and so a slow build up might
actually work better politically let's
get a little wonky with this what would
the political strategy be than heading
into 2024 because at this point I don't
see why the Republicans wouldn't want
Joe Biden to run right I mean you have
all the dirt on him he's not just not
popular he's unpopular yeah even
Democrat voters the vast majority say
we'll take anyone but Biden give me a
ham sandwich and I'll take that over Joe
Biden so to me if you're the Republicans
you want Joe Biden to run he can't he
can't even campaign and now you're
dealing with a situation Cornell West is
going to take votes away from the
Democrat base if Robert F Kennedy Jr
who's calling out the corrupt process
within the Democrat Party decides to run
third party that's going to take even
more votes away from the Democrats now
unfortunately they can't rally behind
Donald Trump but we can get over that as
Republican voters or even independent
voters that are going to vote for Trump
now I just don't even think it's a good
political strategy to me
I say let Joe Biden run make him
campaign that's all I want but they're
not going to convict him so they're
trying to taint as much of his
presidency in his campaign as possible
and get it on the historical record too
I think a couple of points about this I
think Republicans are always so careful
as they should be because propaganda
press will you know rip them apart if
they don't go about this the right way
so they are trying to build a case
unlike the Democrats with Trump who just
went in and railroaded him and they
continue to try to Railroad him and they
don't have any facts and it doesn't
matter right
um so I do think they're trying to build
a case the other thing is when I was
flying here today uh guys from New York
on my plane behind me was a republican
member of Congress who shall go nameless
and this member of Congress recognized
me I recognized them and this person is
sort of establishment sort of
established I wouldn't say swamp but
sort of establishment trying to lay
and I went up to this member and this
member recognized me and we start
talking and I I said
I said I I understand that you were
um trending on Twitter today you
probably guess who it might be but in
any case we had a conversation about the
impeachment and this member of Congress
uh indicated that at least they would
like to see the impeachment done for
sure but wrapped up by like December
31st so they don't want to drag it
through an election year because at
least the establishment members don't
want it to flick back on them right like
they don't want the blowback they think
the Press is going to jump all over them
with this illegitimate impeachment and
so on so they want a lot of time and
distance between the end of the
impeachment no conviction in the Senate
but an impeachment an election day in
November at least that seemed to be the
establishment point of view thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time